okay next question is very related to
the first one
are the college-educated white uh voters
actually becoming more liberal um
there's a very interesting dynamic
that's going on here with
college-educated whites
i talk to you must have been about a
month ago
about the abandonment among some
of the republican party moving to the
democratic party or moving to be
independents who still may vote for
republicans or whatever the case may be
it is absolutely true that this has been
a shift over time
among college-educated white voters
college-educated white voters
some decades ago leaned much more to the
right and it was primarily for economic
reasons
the idea and this came up during the
voicemail segment on monday
the idea being college-educated people
are more likely to make more money
and they want to keep the money so they
vote for republicans because they see
republicans is keeping their taxes low
and that's a very nice concise
little explanation and certainly some
decades ago
there was probably a lot of truth to
that however we've now
seen more college-educated whites over
time
move in the direction of voting for more
and more democrats i think that there
are two things going on here number one
although the republican party is still
seen widely as the low tax
party the daylight between the two
parties has gotten smaller and smaller
now i know joe biden now is talking
about doubling the capital gains rate on
people making over a million dollars and
all these different things but
the vast majority of people don't make
over a million dollars and so when you
think about
college-educated democrats
college-educated voters
making between you know 80 and 180 000
or something like that um they may
actually be realizing
you know the the very small difference
in what i might pay in taxes under the
republican versus democratic plans
is not enough to override all the other
reasons that the college-educated
white voter has been moving to the left
and this includes
social issues uh this includes
cultural elements as well so while the
economics are always
reflexively what we might go to um
social attitudes have changed as well i
mean look at something like approval of
black lives matter
in 2017 if you polled white college
graduates do you support black lives
matter
29 said yes i do that same poll
right now has 40 percent of white
college graduates supporting black lives
matter that's an
increase of almost 33 percent remember
not 30 it's 11 percentage points
but about almost a third about 30
percent
that it appears significantly overrides
oh
my the top tax bracket is three points
lower
under the republican plan and so
that to me seems like a major
factor in what we've seen from
college-educated white voters
moving more to the democratic party
the other thing also that may be going
on is that
as people simply become more politically
aware
they make more rational decisions about
where they say
they align before tr one of the things
that
trump did and we saw it in
absolute record turnout in 2020. trump
getting way more votes than he got in
2016.
biden getting way more votes than anyone
has gotten um
so one of the things that we saw trump
do
for better or worse is engage a lot of
new people
and there are likely lots of
college-educated white voters
who are recently out of college who were
in some nominal way kind of following
the politics of their parents maybe
maybe you maybe had some really you know
21 22 20 year old
uh in college or college graduates that
in 2015
were republicans in some nominal way but
maybe they didn't vote for example as
they became more politically aware i'm
not using the term woke but as they
became more engaged in politics
during the trump era and they more
understood oh wait a second yeah i don't
know what my parents saw in the
republican party but i don't see it with
trump i'm going to become a
democrat for example um i think that
that's a factor as well that sometimes
you just have people who more
as they get more involved they
understand that whatever they were
nominally identifying with originally
really wasn't for them and so that may
be something you see in the numbers
that may not not actually reflect a
shift it may simply reflect a change
from not paying attention to paying
attention
some things to think about let me know
your thoughts on this one